chérie il est 20 heures oui et c'est
quelque chose de très important vous
dire si une allocution que je voulais
faire depuis longtemps
sachez le il y a eu au cours de ces
dernières semaines les attaques au
chocolat ces attaques ont parfois sales
il est chroniqueur dans leur corps dans
leur tête et dans leur chair et le
public et le public également
le public aime la dar k way et on sera
toujours partisan de la targa mais après
ce 1er mai où j'ai beaucoup réfléchi
bien marcher marcher marcher des heures
et des heures pour arriver à cette
conclusion le chocolat gates
ne va pas s'arrêter je me suis fait peur
non non non non pas comme ça non le
chocolat gate ne s'arrêtera pas le
chocolat gates fait à partir de
maintenant devenir encore plus grand
encore plus fort encore plus lourd
encore plus majestueux et enfin il faut
encore plus exceptionnel à votre image à
votre image le chocolat gates va devenir
quoi mondiale je m'adresse aujourd'hui à
tous les chefs d'état qui nous regardent
et poutine
l'e-tron les marrons c'est les deux
chefs d'état que je connais et merkel
mais qui nous regardent et sachez que
j'ai ici le choco bonne peur et dans un
hosto je déclencherai sochaux cow-boy
buzz mais si je mettrai en marche pour
la suite des événements d'accord énorme
et dans un instant vous saurez quelle va
être la fonction de chocobo heures et
tous ceux qui nous regardent que vous
soyez chez vous que vous soyez prêts que
vous soyez loin que vous soyez en
trottinette en overboard là sachez que
super choco vous regarde
oui rigolez pas dans la tronche de
barthez de les chiffrer
tous vous le dit le chocolate va se
délocaliser à a
et vous aussi chez vous pendant qu'il va
vous serez partisans le chocolate
sachez le maintenant à partir de
maintenant le chocolat gates vient à se
délocaliser
car vous aussi vous pourrez
faire partie du chocolat gates et de la
confrérie du chocolat sachez en tout cas
que ce chocolat c'est du chocolat varié
avec de l'eau mettez beaucoup d'eau et
un petit peu de chocolat variés y avions
fait une mixture malade ça on est
rassuré alors d'avoir été pourri enroulé
son esprit c'est pourri non non non non
il n'y a pas de ces pourris les chéris
je vais activer le chocobo there enquête
parce que j'aime couverts par les
pouvoirs du kinder bueno
[Rires]
par toutatis partout x tekken et par
merveilles du monde que ce bonheur qui
deviennent le chocobo heures par les
pouvoirs du calacs ancestrale choco
buzzer
c'est fait sachez qu'à partir de
maintenant
voci direct la productrice julie raynaud
me dise comment faire comment on fait
pour s'inscrire parce que vous aussi
vous allez pouvoir vous allez pouvoir
choco buzz et quelques à chaque jour
chaque jour il ya une adresse mail et
7jours j'appuierai sur ce buzzer et
quelqu'un en france se fera chocobo's et
à quelqu'un quelqu'un qui a dit quelque
chose
ça a été un voilà donc à partir de
maintenant je chocobo's ray tous les
jours ça a fini ses chocobo's tpm paix
at gmail.com vous envoyer un mail ou
sécurité nous expliquer votre cas et au
choc opposera quelqu'un parce que vous
êtes chauds pour le chocobo
[Applaudissements]